if you want to know about the secret
meaning hidden in Ben's poem to Beverly
then stick around at the end of this
video this video is sponsored by Ray
Khan each member of the losers Club
stopped being a loser after beating
Pennywise and leaving dairy the biggest
transformation in adulthood comes from
Ben Hanscom welcome to horror history my
name is the guy from tangled alright I
can see it in today's episode were
taking a look at the life of Ben Hanscom
the strong foundation of the losers Club
and the first to discover its biggest
weakness to find out how he got here
we've got to take it back to the start
of the haystack Ben was born on June 2nd
1946 in Newport Maine about 20 miles
west of Derry Ben's father fought in the
Korean War but was killed the war
started in 1950 so Ben would have been
four years old when he lost his father
his mother Arlene worked in the textile
mill and didn't make much money
causing her to overfeed her son because
she never felt like he was getting
enough we got pen displayed early signs
of his brilliant architectural mind
while playing with Lincoln Long's as a
child they moved to Derry in Ben's fifth
grade year and Ben had a hard time
making friends because he was bullied
for being overweight and was shy this
caused him to become reclusive and he
spent a lot of extra time at school or
at the library in January of 1958 he
stayed after class to help his teacher
mrs. Douglas with the books you have to
understand that back then people learned
things by reading them out of books
rather than watching horror History
videos he refused to accept a ride home
and found himself walking over the canal
bridge where he saw a clown standing on
the ice waving to him the clown cast no
shadow and when it let go of the
balloons it was holding they floated
against the wind which was blowing out
towards Ben Pennywise asks him to come
down into the sewers with him telling
him he'll never have to grow up and
making the sewers seemed like a fair
telling him it'll be fun as Ben gazes
out a hand springs up onto the bridge
and reaches for him Ben is able to
escape but he thinks it's the mummy in a
clown suit the disappearances in town
start to increase and Arlene gives her
son a watch that will always be home on
time for dinner and not out after dark
with the potential kidnapper on the
loose and dare Ben avoids telling his
mom about what happened at the canal not
wanting to lose what little freedom he
had near the end of the school year he
dreamt that he was playing baseball with
the other boys a fantasy likely brought
on by
his desire to have friends and his
self-loathing about his weight its
leading him to imagine himself in an
athletic scenario in the dream he hits a
home run and as he's rounding the bases
he notices a clown staring at him in the
trees he can't remember the rest of the
dream but when he wakes up his pillow is
wet as if he'd cried all the way through
the notes a detail that I found
particularly chilling near the end of
the school year in 1958 - the school
bully Henry Bowers asked Ben to let him
copy during a test but Ben hides his
answers Ben was always considered a good
kid by most of the adults such as his
mother the librarian and his teacher
with whom he wants to stay in good
graces however he quickly comes to
regret the decision after learning of
Henry's previous suspension after
knocking a kids teeth out he hopes that
Henry passed as the final report cards
go out and that maybe he would be off
the hook if he did he's careful to avoid
Henry and his gang when leaving after
the final day of school and on his way
out he runs into his crush a redheaded
girl in his class named Beverly Marsh
he's in a great mood after talking to
her and avoiding Bowers so he stops at
the candy shop before hitting the
library but what he doesn't realize is
that Henry and his thugs saw him go
inside
upon entering he notices the librarian
miss Davies reading the story of the
three Billy Goats Gruff a story about
three Billy Goats who try to cross a
bridge with the troll under it and the
portion she's reading reflects the
struggle that Ben was about to partake
in that summer would the monster be
bested or would his feed been signs up
for the summer reading program and he
notices a postcard display at the desk
so he buys a postcard and writes a haiku
to his crush Beverly your hair is winter
fire January embers my heart burns there
too Ben doesn't fully understand it yet
but love is one of the strongest weapons
that he and the other kids have to fight
against it that's the reason they're
able to beat it when they're all
together at the end of that summer the
reason they're eventually able to escape
the sewers and the reason that they're
able to save Mike from his attacker in
the hospital in 1985 at this point the
only encounter Ben has had with it so
far was on that freezing cold day in
January so the first two lines your hair
is winter fire January embers are a
direct connection to his love for
Beverly guiding him past the evil that
is it his love would not help him
against Henry Bauer so ever who ambushes
him as soon as he leaves the library and
Ben would make one of the most important
decisions of his young
normally here in the Horace tree
classroom I only teach you about horror
history but let me teach you something
about economics
these are ray cons they're half the cost
of other premium wireless earbuds but
with MyLink you're gonna get them even
cheap
I picked these up because I was tired of
my old headset coming loose in my ear
and I was really tired of this wire
hanging down and basically inviting
whoever wants do to come strangle me
with it with ray cones you just put them
in your ear and they stay there
comfortable you can go for a run you can
rock out to your favorite music like I'm
about to right now the sound quality is
top-notch
they put out a clean isolated sound on
par with any other ear but on the market
and that's coming from someone who
spends many hours every week doing high
quality sound mixes this latest model is
the best one yet you get six hours of
playtime that's enough to get you
through almost any domestic flights and
this little charging case as a battery
life of its own getting you a total of
24 hours of battery life they've added
more base packages a nice compact design
and they offer great-looking color
options if you use the link in the
description that's by Ray Khan calm /cz
the world you're gonna be getting 15%
off the already affordable price ditch
the messy wires enjoying the next wave
in audio with Ray con Henry's plan is to
carve his name into Ben's gut so that he
never forgets to let him copy and after
carving the letter H Ben retaliates by
kicking off of Henry and sending himself
tumbling down into the Barrens he ends
up hiding in a divot in the earth behind
some bushes and falls asleep there for a
while dreaming again of Pennywise before
coming out and encountering build n brow
and Eddy Hasbro Henry had taken some of
his frustration out on Eddy who is now
having an asthma attack and Ben agrees
to stay with him while bill runs to get
his medicine then creates a pile of
rocks to use as ammo in case the bullies
come back a foreshadowing of a battle
that would take place the following
month bill returns at half-past four and
the kids introduce themselves to one
another it's at this point that Ben
discovers his role in the group and it
can be seen as both a literal and
metaphorical position Ben is the Builder
he offers to help bill and Eddy rebuild
their dam in the stream and in doing so
also helps build the foundations of the
bloomin friend girl his participation
starts a snowball effect where Ritchie
Stan Beverly and Mike all eventually
join in on top of the foundation set by
Ben Bill
Edea that day in the barren sin also
gives Eddie the idea to spill a
milkshake on himself to hide the blood
on his shirt from his mother I think I
might have mixed that up in a previous
video but it's definitely been who is
the one to get Eddie bad idea on the way
home and then seize the Bowers gang
again waiting for a bus and once again
hides until the bus picks them up the
next day under Ben's leadership they
build the dam and Richie and Stan show
up to help they effectively stop the
water flow of the stream and create a
small bog in the area that they had met
him bill begins to tell the story about
his run-in with Pennywise when the dairy
police officer mister now interrupts
them explains that not only are they
playing in dirty water but their Dam
caused backups in people's drains in
town they end up having to deconstruct
the damn thing but that wouldn't be the
only engineering idea that Ben would
contribute to the group one Saturday not
long after Ben receives a call from
Richie Tozier inviting him to go to a
horror double feature then had no money
to go having spent everything on junk
food habit instilled in him by his
mother's feeding habits but Richie
offers to spot him on the way there Ben
is once again and nearly spotted by
Henry Bowers when he finally did arrive
he was overwhelmed as he found they
would also be joined by Beverly Richie
explains his nickname for Ben haystack
which comes from the professional
wrestler haystack Calhoun the three of
them took the balcony to avoid the
bullies but are still spotted on the way
out and subsequently cornered in the
alley next to the movie theater
Henry belch and Victor stand on one side
while two of Henry's other thugs take
the other side
Bennett always been a good kid and never
getting involved in fights but with
Beverly there he goes berserk on the
Bowers gang he hurls a garbage can at
Henry nothing in mova then he headbutts
Victor and the three are able to escape
and run to the police station which they
stand outside of for a little while
thinking that Henry would have to be
crazy to try to beat them up there and
Henry was crazy but in this instance he
did not pursue them any further one
afternoon bana Eddie and Bradley Donovan
are pitching pennies in Richards alley
the alley next to center street drug
where Eddie gets his medication
when Bev finds and joins up with them
Everly goes up against Bradley and winds
causing Bradley to accuse her of
cheating now Ben didn't think he had a
real chance with Beverly because he was
overweight it's what he valiantly stands
up for her anyway spend bounce to his
feet it was awesome to watch Ben Hanscom
bounce take that back Bradley looked at
Ben his mouth open
what take it back she didn't cheat the
confrontation ended with Bradley tearing
up and running from the alley Ben
Beverly and Eddie decided to get ice
cream frappes from the drugstore and eat
them in the grass at bassy park
kisses Ben on the cheek for standing up
for her and events he would later play
over and over in his head after the
group was joined by Stan Beverly tells
the story of how she saw blood in her
bathroom saying so they all sneaked in
her back door to see if they're able to
see it too
the four of them clean it up together
and take the bloody rags to the
washeteria in town to clean them where
Ben tries to comfort Beverly by telling
her she isn't alone and explaining some
of the other Pennywise settings that
some of them had endured Ben is starting
to understand that his loved her Beverly
and similarly the platonic love shared
among the friends is what gives him the
strength to discuss the horrors that
plagued Derry but he would see a much
greater impact by their power the
following month on July 3rd Mike Hanlon
approaches Ben Bill Beverly Richie Stan
and Eddie at the gravel pits in the
Barrens looking for protection against
Henry Bowers Bennett had more than
enough of Henry terrorizing them and
played a huge part in the rock fight
that would ensue pelting Henry with
rocks then going all off cam Hicks on
him by tackling to the ground after
seeing him hit Beverly with the pebble
one of Henry's big thugs a boy named
moose Sadler took down Ben but all of
his friends had his back and they pelted
moose with rocks until he peeled off the
whole thing only lasted four minutes but
by the end of it Henry and his gang were
gone
Mike had joined the group now called the
losers Club and Ben puked likely a
result of the unexpected uptake in
physical activity combined with the
stress of having to deal with Bowers
once again with the 7 of them together
now they could start planning and how
they might deal with Pennywise but first
Ben had an idea to make sure that Bowers
wouldn't get in their way
again Ben and the others spent most of
that July with another engineering idea
of bands an underground clubhouse with
the dirt covered lid to camouflage it
into the Barrens while they're building
Ritchie tells the group about real rock
and roll not that fake stuff that Ben
listens to
[Music]
if Richie wanted to listen to real
rock'n'roll today he'd used the superior
sound quality of rake honey earbuds buy
rake hon comm /c ZZZ world near the
clubhouses completion they take a break
and mike shows them his father's photo
album containing old shots of dairies
history many of which include
appearances by penny wise Mike turns to
one photo that goes into motion and
emits sound like a movie everyone in the
picture turns away from Pennywise who
runs up to the losers threatening to
kill them all and one of the forms it
takes is the moment that Bennett's seen
on the canal in January they went on to
finish the clubhouse in mid-july and on
the 17th the cop that made them take
down the dam before mr. nail came along
and sat right on top of it without even
realizing Ben's design had worked to a
tee but the real test would come later
that summer but before that happened Ben
had another idea of how they could
possibly use the clubhouse and told the
others about an Indian ceremony known as
the smoke hole ritual the idea was that
tribal chiefs trying to reach a decision
would sit around a fire inside of a
smoke hole and breathe in the smoke
which was supposed to give them visions
showing them the path forward please
don't try this though I don't want
anything to happen to any of you because
my view count will go down I think Ben
realized the danger pretty quickly and
he was the second one to climb out but I
do think that this milk hole represents
another instance of the motif
established in Ben's poem in Beverly
where fire represents love which is
something that aids them in their battle
against Pennywise the smoke that fills
their clubhouse is also the result of a
burning flame and the outcome is Ritchie
and Mike being shown the origin of it
which helps them understand what they're
up against after a warning about Henry's
deteriorating sanity from one of the
other bullies Victor Chris and a clear
example of his lack of sanity when Henry
breaks Eddie's arm the losers continue
to develop their plan to take on it but
one incident in late July rushes their
plan into action
Beverly witness is a boy named Patrick
hochstätter being attacked by it's in
the form of a swarm of flying legions
bill breaks down in the rain and asked
the others to help him take down the
monster and Ben and the others join him
in a group embrace besides Eddie yeah
Eddie wasn't there for that on July 23rd
wearing a large pair of wrap arounds
turtle sunglasses for protection Ben and
melts down the silver dollars given to
him by his father with a blowtorch in
the den bros garage to create the silver
slugs that would be used as ammunition
and two days later when the losers
arrived at Twentynine kneeble streets
this was Ben's first time seeing in the
house and the scent reminds him of what
he imagines the mummy would smell like
they all crawled into the basement
window under the Porsche and then got
stuck in the window frame which was
extremely embarrassing
especially in front of Beverly
eventually he's able to pass through and
the seven losers go upstairs there's
something described as a girly book in
the corner which I assume is basically
the 1950's version of the hub and when
Ben glances at it the cover girl winks
at him this is obviously one of the
manipulations of it's this one in
particular fits in with the themes of
growing up and reaching adolescence the
process that begins immediately when
they defeat it's at the end of the
summer when they go on into the parlor
and the room seemed too big to fit
inside of the house kind of like in a
video game where you go in somewhere and
the inside is way bigger
it speaks to Ben inside of his head
telling him that on the outside things
always look bigger
possibly a taunt about Ben's weights as
this is happening the others continue on
and nearly lose Ben so they all make
sure to stay together after that they
come up to three doors and discover a
destroyed bathroom behind the last one
Ben finds a pipe and looks down into it
when he's hit by a thought it was
rushing toward them moving at an express
train speed filling the throat of this
dark pipe from side to side it was in
its own form now whatever that might be
it would take some shape from their
minds when it got here and when it
exploded from the pipe it was in the
form of the werewolf like from the movie
that rich he had brought Ben along to
see after narrowly missing bill it came
after Ben Ben thrust his thumb into its
eye but he received a slash in the
stomach from the monsters claws they
would later evaluate this injury and
decide that it's bad but not quite deep
enough to get to Ben's guts if that
really was its intention it makes sense
because at the end of their story in
1985 it's ultimately defeated when bill
and Ritchie pulled the creatures heart
out to crush it as they're leaving the
kneeble house Ben has an epiphany about
power and maybe for the first time truly
realizes the power of the silver slugs
because of their belief in them and the
power of love not much goes on for the
next two weeks but Ben does think more
about the idea that the shape-shifting
it may have some kind of standard form
but he doesn't think that they've seen
it yet Dave the big battle would come on
August 10th but this time the losers
Club wouldn't have a chance to confront
it on their own terms
one day in early August Ben hangs out of
the Barrens with the box of Junior Mints
and a funny book none of the others are
there yet and the first to show up is
Beverly who runs up to him in a path
shut everything she panted hurry up Ben
for heaven's sake they're coming
who Andrey and his friends Henry's gone
crazy he's got a knife upon hearing this
Ben actually dropped his Junior Mints
and funny book and pulled down the hatch
about the clubhouse yeah he actually
dropped his junior man's been dropped
junk food on the ground
if that doesn't Ellis trait the
seriousness of the situation I don't
know what well the regular butterball
I've hugged him tightly as the bullies
came by and stood on the lid the two
struggled not to laugh at the pure
stupidity of one of belches jokes and on
top of that the roof was starting to
cave under their ways but somehow Bowers
and his gang headed off in a different
direction and Ben and Beverly are able
to escape before leaving she tells him
she knows it was him and wrote the poem
and after denying it at first he admits
that it was him
Bev tells him that she loves all of them
probably not what Ben was hoping to hear
I mean something just tells me that he
wasn't fantasizing about sharing Bev
with the other five dudes when he wrote
that poem on the last day of school Ben
and Beverley get up and go to find and
warn the others about Henry and they end
up going back to the Barrens since
they've now realized that no word that
they go was safe and maybe the time has
come to take on it bill asked Ben to
lead them to the pumping station and on
the way they're spotted by Bowers and
company who chase after them as a storm
approaches the losers somehow managed to
escape the bullies and descend into the
sewer to take on it when they arrive in
the chamber where it was deep below the
town of Derry they find it's in the form
of a giant spider Ben is the only one of
the losers Club was able to comprehend
that there's some kind of shape moving
around behind the lights what he's
seeing is the true form of it the dead
lights and the abstract nature of what
it really is terrifies them perhaps the
only thing that gives him the extra
courage to go on was Beverly who asked
Ben to lend some of his power to Bill
who engages in the mind-to-mind ritual
with the monster and wins driving it
into a panic and deeper down into the
sewer
spen like many of the others had the
sense that it was dying and the kids
escaped from the now flooding chamber
when they emerged back into the Barrens
the storm is over but
conducted river is high and overflowing
Ben and his friends had disrupted the
pattern of horrible events in town by
defeating Pennywise and just as they had
disrupted the flow of the stream and the
Barons at the beginning of that summer
the area was starting to flood as a
result flushing out the evil that rested
in the pipes below Derry but at some
points the flooding stopped and I think
some small part of each of them knew
that they hadn't fully finished off it
as they made a Blood Pact agreeing that
wherever they weren't they would come
back should the shape-shifting entity
threaten the city again defeating it had
an immediate effect on all of them it
kick-started their transition from
child's to adulthood Ben continued to
live in Derry for the next two years
until his mom lost her job in 1960 and
the two were forced to move out to
Nebraska with his Angie in the
miniseries that's done a bit differently
Bennet his mom actually come to Derry to
stay with his aunt while Arlene gets
back on her feet and Ben has to deal
with his ol cousin Kristi duty that's
that's rich Ben's Aunt Jean was
constantly nagging him to lose weight so
he got fatter out of spikes by the time
he started at Eastside high school in
Omaha
he had reached 1210 pounds but at the
corner if Ben thought he had escaped
being bullied for his weight when Henry
Bowers was locked up in Augusta Asylum
after the fall of its he would have been
sorely mistaken because the guys in the
locker room after gym class in high
school would slap Ben in the guts and
make fun of them one time it got so bad
he screamed out and fled into the
hallway half naked they chased me up the
hall past the lockers they got me down
and they started slapping me and the
coach found me lying there I was crying
I thought he was gonna help me he didn't
the coach just told him to shut up and
squeezed his tits calling him disgusting
instead that his problem was he was fat
in his head basically suggesting that
Ben's eating disorder was mostly mental
Ben thought back to what he and his
friends had accomplished when they put
their minds to defeating it in 1958 I
said coach you coach track riding sort
of sneered at me and nodded and I said
well you listen to me you still bring
some of the I'm gonna go out for the
track team in March I'm gonna run down
everything you got
I'm gonna run down your best and then I
wanna flip in apology from you
the coach told them he'd quit his job
when that happens then went home and
told his mom he wanted to lose weight
at first she was concerned that he
wasn't eating enough but Ben enrolled in
a health and nutrition class at school
and figured out he could eat a ton of
salad and still lose ways and
mom felt better about it as long as he
was eating something he started running
everywhere he got a newspaper delivery
routes went through pairs and pairs of
new clothes and also picked up a pair of
ray con earbuds for 50% off using the
link in the description these things
don't come loose from your ear when you
run it's amazing by March I lost 70
pounds and I had grown two inches every
time I ran I felt like I could fly
anyone up I went out for track just like
I said on first day I was out there I
won the 220 and the for 40 I just blew
away the coaches the best guys when Ben
wants to get his apology he instead got
a punch to the face he didn't say a
thing at first just swung a roundhouse
and knocked me flat on my back then he
told me to get off the field said he
didn't want a smart-mouth bastard like
me on his track team I wouldn't be on it
if President Kennedy appointed me to it
I said wiping the blood out of the
corner of my mouth
Ben was excused from that coaches PE
class in the following year in 1963 the
coach had been wrong about the fat being
in Ben's head it really started with his
mother and consequently Ben started to
use junk food as a crutch to comfort
himself but after having defeated it he
no longer needed that crutch like he
used to
after moving on from the losers Club Ben
was no longer the fat loser he once was
the boy who was left out of baseball
games his child and dairy was now one of
the most athletic kids in school a
couple years later it was time for Ben
to move on again as he graduated high
school and once again went west for
college
you
after graduating from college Ben became
one of the most successful architects in
North America even getting the honor of
designing the BBC communication Center
in London he modeled it after the Derry
Public Library which had a slim glass
tube that connected the children's
library with the adult section this
could represent the fact that Ben
himself had to slim down and his
transition from childhood to adulthood
the communication centre was basically
the dairy library turned 90 degrees he
became so successful that he managed to
afford himself his own Learjet plane and
his very own landing strip near Omaha in
1985 Mike Hamlin called him up to let
him know that it was back and the return
of his memories from Derry hit Ben aw he
showed up at a bar called the red wheel
and downed a whole Stein of whiskey
after snorting droplets of lemon juice
which was supposed to neutralize the
effects of the alcohol I looked it up
and there doesn't seem to be any
scientific basis for this claim but when
Ben walked out of the bar the bartender
sensed that he wasn't drunk in the
slightest so this must have been another
instance of the power of belief just as
he believed that silver could kill it as
a child before leaving he hands the
bartender of three silver dollars to
give to his kids the same ones that his
father had given him all of those years
ago the fourth had been melted down to
use his ammunition against Pennywise in
1958 Ben's flight to Maine has a layover
in Chicago and the stewardess
momentarily thinks that he's dead as he
sleeps through the rough flight Ben
meets with his long-lost friends at a
reunion lunch in a private room at Jade
of the Orient then reveals that he
doesn't really remember much of what
took place that summer outside of bill
screaming something about deadlines he
also finds that they all have something
in common
each of them is childless in Ben's case
because he never married the fortune
cookies contain individual fears that
each of them have Ben's contains a pair
of bloody teeth perhaps the teeth
represent a connection to the mouth
which had been used to eat a lot of junk
food and became overweight or maybe
there was some fear that Ben had about
Henry Bowers catching up with him and
knocking his teeth out before they can
kill it they need to regain some of
their old memories so each of them sets
out on a personal journey on foot in
Derry Ben walks down the street and sees
a turtle drawn in the sidewalk in chalk
a connection to the rival entity of it
so that I talked about in my Pennywise
horror history episode Ben closes his
eyes and reopens them to find that there
was just a hop stop grid no turtle in
sight he goes to where he spent a lot of
his time when he was young the Derry
Public Library in the miniseries Ritchie
is the one to visit librarian miss
Davies is no longer there but a young
new librarian Carol Danner reads the
story suggesting that he too would have
one more major confrontation with the
monster from below to his surprise he
hears Pennywise voice come from above
it's standing in the area of the library
known as the stats with empty sockets
words I should have been and holding a
balloon
Pennywise taunts been using one of
Ritchie's voices then transforms into
Dracula because I guess it just loves
using Universal monster movie icons
against Ben and then disappears leaving
behind a balloon with the text have a
good day tonight you die before leaving
the library Ben asked around about mrs.
starett the librarian who had helped him
when he was young only to find that she
had passed away then he finds another
balloon that says I killed the Barbara
stare he checks out one book bulldozer
one of the same books that had taken out
the day that he was jumped by Henry
Bowers he previously thought that it was
lost where he fell into the barrels but
it looks at the card on the inside and
discovers that it is in fact the same
copy then like many of the others is
experiencing things and events from the
summer of 58 re-emerging that nice they
all reconvene at the library where Ben
is finally able to remember what he did
with the fourth Silver Dollar how they
had melted it down to create the slugs
that were fired at Pennywise then bill
Beverley Eddie and Ritchie returned to
their hotel to go get some rest with the
hope of meeting up the next morning to
go down into the Barrens as he sleeps
that evening a call comes through to
Ben's room telling him to come to
Eddie's room and without hesitation he
springs out of bed and rushes to the
scene where he learns Eddie has been
attacked by an escaped Henry Bowers and
Mike has also been hospitalized by Henry
earlier in the night span in Beverly
Ritchie Eddie and Bill decide that they
can't wait until morning it needed to be
taken care of now and head for the
Barrens where they would walk down to
the same pumping station that they've
used to descend into the sewers 27 years
prior once again bill asked Ben to leave
them there and although bushes and
shrubs had grown in to reclaim the
clearing that they once played in he
guides them past the now cast aside
Clubhouse door to the pumping station
like the day that they had originally
conquered it's the machine parts had
been turned off and they're able to
climb down into the sewers once more
they make it back to the inner sanctum
and are faced once again with the giant
spider this time they realized that it
has
: egg sack essentially telling them that
it is pregnant with its soon to hatch
offspring bill once again takes part in
the mind-to-mind battle with it this
time Ritchie has to join in in save Bill
and the two of them come back from the
macro verse after badly damaging the
monster not wanting to let it get away
again they go on after it Beverley tends
to be injured Eddie leaving Ben is the
only one who can try to eliminate the
massive eggs that had been laid across
the floor of the chamber he stomps down
in the first day and the smaller rat
sized spider tries to crawl away been
lurched after it on legs that felt like
stilts and brought his foot down again
he felt the spiders body crunch and
splatter under the heel of his boots his
Gorge clenched and this time there was
no way he could hold back he vomited and
then twisted his heel grinding the thing
into the stones listening to the cries
in his head
fade to nothing as the light in the
chamber died he repeated the process and
each egg he could find until he had
stamped out about a hundred thinking
that he'd gotten them all it reconvenes
with Beverly Ritchie and Bill they
defeated it and this time it would not
be reawakening been enriched he helped
bring Bill's wife who they had rescued
from the spider's web but was now a
vegetable out of the sewers they walked
for a long way in the dark not even sure
they were going the right way with Eddie
no longer there to guide them and Ben is
the first one to recognize the object
peeking through the crack in the top of
the pipe it was the marquee of the
Aladdin theatre which had been destroyed
in the storm that took place during the
battle like the last time they fought
it's there was some flooding when they
reached the surface but this time they
could be sure that they'd finished it
off because the damage was much worse
destroying almost every building in the
downtown area after having one last
breakfast with the losers or what
remained of them then decided to head
back to Nebraska but this time things
would be different after growing closer
to Beverly again and after her once
again realizing that Ben was the one
that wrote the poem that she adored so
much back then and the 27 years that
would follow he would have a companion
this time as he trekked back to the
Midwest
Bradley Donovan no I'm just kidding it
was Bev on June 5th 1985 the two set out
together and when Mike next talks to
them he gets the distinct feeling that
they're going to get married Ben Hanscom
built the foundations of the losers Club
whether it was his brilliant
architectural mind helping them achieve
things that most kids could never dream
of or his love for his friends and his
future wife that held the group together
and inspired them to push for so
remember what you learned today kids
Bradley Donovan is a little girls will
only like you if you'd become attractive
but you also have to watch the others in
support history in order to be
attractive so make sure you check out
that play
some left and subscribe to seize these
worlds for new Horrors every week bring
the death bound form notifications and I
will see you in the next one we've got
one more is character to cover Bradley
done I'm done